الطالب الجامعي ميخائيل سوهارود شين
بعد رؤية الفظائع التي ارتكبتها
القوات الروسية في بوشا ، قام برش
عبارة بوتين يساوي الحرب على الحائط بعد
يومين قال إن الشرطة
تعقبته واستجوبته وضربته بمجرد
إطلاق سراحه وقرر أن الوقت قد حان
للفرار  روسيا جايل تنضم إلينا الليلة من
باريس
ميخائيل بعد أن سمعت طرقا على
بابك قمت بفتحه جاءت الشرطة
في ما حدث
آه حسنًا لقد كان الأمر بسيطًا جدًا لقد تم
احتجازي تم وضعي على الأرض
وعرضت علي كل مذكرة التفتيش  من
شقتي واستمر البحث
أه كان سريعًا جدًا وبدا
أم
أه حلمًا سيئًا حتى أكون منصفًا
أفهم أنهم أحضروا لك مركز الشرطة
واستجوبك محقق
وبمجرد الانتهاء من ذلك
دخل ثلاثة رجال إلى الغرفة ما حدث
أه
لقد فقدت رأسين أه وأم في الحائط
لقد أمرت بالوقوف إلى الحائط
ثم سئلت أسئلة أه تعرضت
للتهديد أه عندما طرحت مثل هذه
الأسئلة ليس في طريقة هذا الرجل مع
قبلني أن أطلب الرد عليهم
لقد ضربت أه ضربت على رقبتي وضربت
مرتين على كتفي
وهددت أه الرجل الذي كان
يفعل هذا
هددني بضرب أصابعي
بالمطرقة  وطردني
مني في جامعتي وهو
ما سيخضعني للمسودة
ماذا كانوا يريدون منك ما الذي
كانوا يريدون منك أن تقوله
أه أعتقد أنهم يريدونني أن أخبر من
أه يريدون أنا أعتقد أنهم يريدونني
أه أخبر أه من وراء هذا أه
الكتابة على الحائط لم يصدقوا
أنها كانت فكرتي الخاصة ولكن بعد ذلك عندما
اتضح أنها بالفعل فكرتي الخاصة ،
أرادوا مني فقط أن أعترف
بأنها كانت خاطئة وأنهم  أردت أن أجعل
مقطع فيديو مثالًا لي
أجنبيًا وهل قمت أخيرًا بعمل هذا الفيديو
تحت الضغط
نعم تحت الضغط لقد
كسرته وقمت بعمل الفيديو الذي ذكر
أنني أحب بوتين أنني أؤيد
أفعاله في أوكرانيا وهي كذبة واه
تحت  تم إنشاء هذا الفيديو وتركت
لماذا فعلت  قررت أن ترش الطلاء
بوتين يساوي الحرب على الحائط
أه لأنني شعرت أنه بعد
الجزار المكسيكي شعرت أنه يمكنني أن لا
أملك الحق في أن أكون خاملاً وأنني بحاجة إلى فعل
أي شيء على الأقل لإثبات أنني  غير
راضين عن هذه المأساة والقتل